whenever we think about the cause of
cancer
we very often think cancer is caused due
to mutagens such as
uv rays cigarette smoke car smoke etc
but many of us don't know that cancer
could also be caused
due to gene mutation or even by
viruses so in this video our focus
is how cancer could be caused by viruses
and what is the role of viruses in terms
of causing cancer
virus could be also a cancer-causing
agent came from the work of peyton
rouse in early 1918
and peyton rouse did a very simple
experiment
he was called in in a poultry farmer's
house to
analyze some chickens which are having
tumors in their legs
and that is known as sarcoma
so first virus to be detected
as cancer-causing agent was
rouse sarcoma virus and it was termed as
a oncovirus
now rao sarcoma virus called sarcoma in
chicken and it's a
retrovirus it has rna as a genetic
material
so we look at the functionality of it
and how it can cause cancer
so let us look at what experiment
exactly
was performed by him so he observed
that in chicken leg there is growth and
this is sarcoma
so he took a sample of this sarcoma he
cut a portion of this tissue
and homogenized that tissue nicely
after homogenization from the
homogeneity he filtered
this thing and cell-free filtrate
was then injected on a healthy chicken
and what he can show that after
injecting the filtrate
the healthy chicken also develops
sarcoma and his conclusion was
the agent or the causal agent that is
resulting in
sarcoma formation can be transmitted
from one organism to another organism
yeah by that time he didn't know that
this sarcoma is actually caused by a
virus
later on howard tenim developed an
acid where he
can transform chicken's embryonic
fibroblast
into an altered morphology using rao
sarcoma virus infection
so he has extracted cheek fibroblast and
put it in culture
now he can infect this culture with
rouse sarcoma virus and what he can see
these fibroblasts are transformed
in nature that means raw sarcoma virus
has a profound importance in terms of
transforming normal fibroblasts into
uh transformed fibroblast and now
rao's experiment makes sense
whatever he thought as an agent that can
cause
or that can be transmitted from one
individual to another individual was
actually this virus
now tenim also took the approach
of piton rouse he extracted
samples from the sarcoma he ground it up
he filtered it with specific filters
such that only biomolecule can remain
any other cellular components can go
away
and injecting that filter into a healthy
chicken develops sarcoma
in that particular chicken that means
viral derived elements are responsible
for this cancer so let us look at a
little bit about
rao sarcoma virus so rao sarcoma virus
have rna as a genetic material which can
eventually be converted
to a double-stranded cdna which
integrates
inside the host genome now using the
host genomic machinery
it is getting expressed and the major
proteins that are expressed from this
genome
is gag ball and envelope the major genes
that are encoding
proteins are gag pollen envelope now
from paul gene there are reverse
transcriptase integras and protease
these proteins are produced just like an
hiv virus but along with that
the disease-causing gene turned out to
be
sarc it was named as v sarc or viral
sarc
but this sarc has very similarity to a
cellular version of it or c sarc
now what is actually v sarc and c-ser so
let's look at it
so rao sarcoma viruses
rna was taken out and cdna was prepared
from that
now using that cdna derived from rao
sarcoma virus
chicken cdna library was hybridized
and they found out that there are
hybridization between
the rao sarcoma virus derived v sarc
and a particular portion
of the genome of chicken that means the
v
sarc gene is not exclusive to the virus
it is also present in the chicken and it
is present in many of these
animals in our animal kingdom so the
visa
the visa gene is essential for
proliferation of the virus but it it
increases the virulence property this
arc is nothing but a kinase
which regulates a bunch of pathway it
modulates
map kinase cascade wind signaling jack
stat signaling to name a few
so it is very important in terms of
regulating growth signaling pathway
and as a result you can imagine if the
src kinase is constitutively active all
of these signaling pathway are activated
for a very long time resulting in
uncontrolled and unchecked growth
which might be a leading cause of cancer
so indeed
the vsark has a short structure it
doesn't have a
short residue from the c terminal end
which
leads to its constitutive activation
that means vsarc
is always activated and it can cause
uncontrolled proliferation by activating
many
mitogenic pathways in the host cell
and it results in uncontrolled
proliferation which leads to cancer
so in this video what we learned about
is how
virus can cause cancer how it was
detected
that virus can be a cause of cancer an
exact
mechanism by which rouse sarcoma virus
can
lead to cancer we have learned in this
video so i hope you
enjoyed this video but before we end i
just wanted to let you know
that there are many other viruses such
as hepatitis viruses there are
papillomaviruses there are epstein-barr
viruses which can lead to
several type of cancer and now there are
hundreds of viruses which are discovered
in context of cancer
and the list is growing so
what we learned so far in this video is
mutagens are not the sole cause of
cancer it can also be caused due to
oncoviruses and it can also be caused
due to genetic reasons
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up and don't forget to like share and
subscribe and do let me know in the
comment how do you like my videos
thank you thanks for listening